[Música]
y llegó el momento de repasar la prensa
internacional esto con rosa pérez más
rosa ya llegamos al viernes esta semana
densa de información lo que ha ocurrido
por supuesto en ucrania y ante todo esto
hay una batalla por la narrativa vamos a
ir a the gardian que titula soldados
rusos
desmoralizado dicen estar enfadados por
haber sido engañados para ir a la guerra
porque rosa bueno esto ya raúl pues como
dice es una semana densa
informativamente y eso también afecta
que circulan muchas informaciones por un
lado y por otro para participar no de
esta propaganda bélica característica de
estos contextos de guerra y precisamente
the gardian comenta que si bien es
verdad que circulan vídeos de soldados
rusos rindiéndose que son vídeos que
ucrania usa a su favor no a modo de
propaganda es cierto que hay un
sentimiento de arrepentimiento entre las
tropas rusas señala que muchos de los
reclutas rusos nacieron entre el 2000 y
el 2001 no o sea tienen 20 años de 21
que fueron digamos convencidos de que
serían recibidos en ucrania a modo de
libertadores no entre pues ramos de
flores y vítores sin embargo pues que se
dan cuenta pues que la situación no es
exactamente la que les fue descrita y de
hecho hay un vídeo donde cinco soldados
rusos son arrestados por las tropas
ucranianas una general ucraniano
pregunta a uno de los soldados rusos qué
quiere decir a sus compañeros
del ejército ruso y él dice no se
engañaron creo que el 90% de nosotros
estaría de acuerdo en volver a casa y
dejar de anna señala que podría ser que
esta baja moral entre las filas rusas
sea una de las razones por la que esta
guerra no no se ha ganado de forma tan
rápida como esperaba el kremlin en un
inicio rosa ni en el kiev post y el new
york times' encontramos la tribuna de
opinión del jefe de la oficina
presidencial de ucrania que dice andy
yermack pues evidentemente raúl andrew
yerma que utiliza una plataforma
comunicativa tan importante como es el
new york james para hacer un llamado a
la comunidad internacional más bien
occidental de que aumenten su apoyo a
ucrania
básicamente andrej jermán viene a hacer
una especie de advertencia de ya os
llegar a putin no se va a detener en
ucrania dice escribo desde el búnker de
la capital con el presidente volodymyr
selenski a mi lado durante una semana
las bombas rusas han caído sobre
nuestras cabezas a pesar del constante
fuego ruso nos mantenemos firmes y
unidos en nuestra determinación de
derrotar a los invasores dice otros
autócratas están tomando nota y pueden
hacer una coalición del mal y como te
decía hacen una llamada occidente a lo
que comentaba en los noticieros crear
esta zona de exclusión aérea incluso
expulsar a rusia de naciones unidas dice
sabe que la otan no quiere un conflicto
directo con rusia pero que pues si no es
ahora dice puede ser en un futuro no tan
lejano dice estar a nuestro lado hoy
implica asegurarnos que la historia no
se repite y que nuestro futuro no será
un eco de los tiempos más oscuros de
europa
vamos a ver ahora los que avanzábamos en
nuestro sumario como sea q desde el
incendio una planta nuclear de sabor y
ya vamos a ver la tercera en chile y el
lemon en francia
bueno raúl pues exactamente el pánico ha
sido tal ante el incendio en esta planta
nuclear que hasta un medio chileno como
la tercera lo lleva en una portada y
básicamente como comentaba es dice a tap
ataque de tropas rusas a la mayor planta
nuclear en europa revive el fantasma de
chernóbil limón también este medio
francés titula la central nuclear más
grande de europa ocupada por el ejército
ruso tras ser bombardeada sea como sea
ya recordamos que el incendio está
controlado y que la agencia
internacional de la energía atómica
asegura que no aumentaron los niveles de
radioactividad sin embargo el director
de la agencia ha asegurado que está
dispuesto a viajar a ucrania para llegar
a un acuerdo para que se protejan
especialmente las plantas nucleares
porque un ataque directo pues a un
reactor podría tener unas consecuencias
incalculables sea como sea encontramos
que la tercera al limón la mayoría de la
prensa
da por hecho que este incendio fue
provocado por las tropas rusas pero
veamos a él lo que titula la prensa rusa
raúl así es de rosa vamos a ver entonces
lo que dice al respecto le pregunto hay
silencio sobre esto o si lo reseña pues
hay una mezcla de los dos por un lado
nos fijamos en él con solo mes que ya
pravda y védomosti que no titulan nada
al respecto a este incidente pues no
tiene cabida entre las noticias
destacadas de su portada pero sin
embargo rt sí que hace referencia a este
asunto y asegura lo que tú también ha
destacado en los noticieros que este
accidente ha sido provocado por
nacionalistas ucranianos tal y como
asegura el ministerio de defensa de
moscú y que estas autoridades rusas
dicen que este accidente significa una
completa pérdida de control del
presidente selenski sobre los grupos de
sabotaje ucranianos con mercenarios
extranjeros
rosa vamos ahora a cerrar nuestra
revista de prensa de hoy viernes con las
portadas de the economist times son
fotografías ilustraciones
además comunican como siempre
característico de estas portadas un
mensaje contundente y claro así es raúl
pues como vemos no son fotos de sangre
hemos visto muchísimas no fotos
devastadoras pues en cualquier contexto
bélico pero vemos aquí la bandera de
ucrania ensangrentada en esta portada de
the economist o en la revista 'time'
vemos también la bandera de ucrania con
una inscripción en ucraniano en
referencia al discurso de volodymyr
selenski el presidente de ucrania ante
el parlamento europeo el 1 de marzo una
pues un extracto de las que fueran sus
palabras la vida vencerá sobre la muerte
y la luz vencerá sobre las tinieblas y
por último esta viñeta del kiev post de
este medio ucraniano que muestra pues a
vladimir putin en estas mesas tan largas
no a las que nos tiene acostumbrados
convertida pues en un ataúd
rosa gracias por toda la información
esperemos que la semana que viene todo
esté un poco más calmado el tiempo nos
dirá en todo caso vamos a seguir aquí al
pie del cañón informando todo lo que
ocurre en el mundo y por supuesto en
este conflicto donde nosotros en directo
américa nos hemos enfocado